[Music]
reading leia leads a brave resistance
that will only account for five minutes
of screen time for a legendary character
long after you've either finished
reading that or dismissed it altogether
it's still scrolling by dark shadow of
an evil ship gives the finger to an
audience hoping not to see a remake of a
new hope also the Star Destroyer shadow
is this large and looming then it's are
they're super close to this galaxy Sun
or else this is a tiny ass planet or
you're just having fun with visuals and
don't really care about scale bb-8 is an
obvious attempt to sell toys where can i
buy one here this is how you close your
hand without the Jedi that can be no
balance in the fourth funny since I once
heard that Anakin was prophesied to
bring balance to the force and he
weren't no Jedi well not long term
anyway look I realize you don't wanna
get shot at but I was taking control of
a ship cannon instead of taking off a
good idea here thankfully for the plot
those two overachiever stormtroopers who
shot at him actually damaged his ship
enough to keep him from taking off I
guess they missed the memo about how
they're supposed to be horrible at
aiming take this I learned about this
from the historical documents Leia did
it 38 years ago so it should work for us
also why is it safer with a dumbass
droid than a savvy pro pilot human being
couldn't you've literally bury it in the
sand and it'd be safer than with either
one of you assholes here let me mark you
so people can tell you're the conflicted
stormtrooper oh yeah before I die there
is another Skywalker a mom just
Skywalker
wait a minute a guy who vanished left
behind a map like a physical map any
asshole could stumble upon and find you
with but this movie should have said at
the beginning once Luke Skywalker has
set everyone on a scavenger hunt it's
like a mad mad mad mad world in space I
have to take two sins off here for kylo
ren's stopping the blaster shot in
midair something we've never seen anyone
in a Star Wars movie do so the tux first
heat up first I tell first hilarious
2015 style line makes its way into not
hilarious scene from a galaxy long ago
and far far away that guy shot at me and
definitely was given the map by the old
dude let's take him prisoner for later
in it nor him for now even though the
map could literally be 5 feet away
brilliant kylo ren's senses the finns
stormtroopers rebellious thoughts then
does nothing because he knows finn is
important to the plot later I guess well
I think it's cool that kylo ren's
stopped this blaster bolt in midair was
he really dedicating some of his dark
power to keep it in midair the whole
time that one explosion must mean Poe
died I wish they'd never programmed
oppression inside of me
and PO appears to be the only prisoner
they took from the planet I guess
because Kyla was so sure he knew about
the map but then so did the Max von
Sydow scary and kylo just wasted that
guy's ass on the planet's surface so
what gives finn drooper walks in here
and there is no one on the left side but
as soon as he removes his helmet boom
sudden captain phasma in its quest to be
unique in star wars ii and movie
unfortunately rips off oblivion discount
Tatooine
why does she Park her speeder all the
way out here by itself especially when
she has to fucking drag all his heavy it
a long distance after parking what you
brought me today is worth one quarter
portion game stopped ray doesn't know
about the five count diagonal slash
method of Lyon County I mean are you
supposed to count this with a glance
this thing probably died because it was
trying to walk in a desert
luckily bb-8 is found by someone who is
profoundly important to the story no one
has been able to get out of eating what
you did with the map why waste time with
human torture if your residents if
people can just mind extract the
information out of the subject why not
just start with this it's in the drawer
oh baby let's leave this prisoner I got
that information for him alive for now
just in case we all forget that
information I just force grab from his
brain definitely don't kill this dude
okay got it
follow the girl and get that droid damn
dude you clearly had other customers
behind rain when she left I mean after
you gave that order else do you have to
do Ren wants to presidents I know it's
hard to believe but you should totally
trust me he sent the recently disgraced
storm trooper to do that job following
zero protocols why in the point is there
a tether on this Thai fighter all right
we gotta take out as many of these
cannons as we can we're not gonna get
very far
hey why not just fly perpendicular to
the ship like a way engine eventually
the cannons will be out of range to hit
you right do you have to attack them or
could you maybe just dodge their fire
for a few seconds and leave can we get
to the introductions after you're out of
danger fn-2187 reported well evaluated
and century conditions but obviously not
because he was simply allowed to wander
freely about the ship somehow upon crash
landing Finn and Poe end up super far
away from each other which is sort of
crucial to the plot but not very logical
good thing Poe left his jacket behind
for no reason so that Finn could pick it
up and be seen by bb-8 later is the
desert eating this ship why didn't it do
that to all the other rich ships on the
planet instead of just calling out to
Finn and maybe trying to talk to him
normally Ray goes into full attack mode
immediately because bb-8 thinks he sees
Poe's apparently one-of-a-kind brown
jacket
what's the hummus nice ray apparently
works for the Ferguson Police Department
it was a myth but why wouldn't it be in
all the history books and news and what
they survived this yr the TIE fighter is
just blowing up everything on the planet
and wouldn't they have strict orders not
to do that since the whole point of this
is to get a stupid map a stupid map that
they could easily destroy by doing this
[Music]
and the bad guys be close enough to
obliterate this one ship and sure we
noticed them running for the Falcon but
not obliterate the Falcon before they
can fire it up and take off also
Millennium Falcon just happens to be on
jakku for some reason apparently every
ship in the universe is easy to access
requiring no keys or combinations of any
kind and are ready to fly on a moment's
notice that should be the end of the
journey right there I'm getting pretty
good at this that's great good don't get
cocky
[Music]
once in removed for awesomeness and
after that there were no more bad guys
even though the stardestroyer with kylo
Ren and redheaded Hitler was presumably
just orbiting this planet in fact here's
a Star Destroyer just chillin out near
jakku who did not see finn and rey
escape the planet in the Falcon just FYI
we were unable to acquire the droid on
jakku okay so this leads to an
entertaining scene where kylo goes
ballistic with his satan saber and
wrecks a bunch of computers but my
question is all you need is a droid with
a map inside it why didn't you go down
there and get it why are you that much
of a stickler about letting minions do
the work when this map is so important
you could have taken it easily the two
were accompanied by a girl excessive use
of the force okay god damn it I'm gonna
remove three sins for this yeah solo and
chewbacca one question though
why the fuck are they flying around in
this system at this very moment in time
they just happen to find their old ship
like it was gifted to them and yeah they
were looking for a signal but they still
got you're right when Rey and Finn got
into space stay there until I say so and
don't even think about taking the fall
what about bb-8 stays with me until i
get rid of the gang but why wouldn't it
be safer for bb-8 to stay hidden movie
earns an extra 10 cents for the colossal
waste of talent and hiring the two guys
from the raid do only to have them say a
few lines and get eaten by the spaghetti
monster and promptly waste them that BB
unit first thought thought is looking
for one just like it
well damn Tom's great plan to have bb-8
with him for reasons unexplained just
backfire I got a bad feeling about this
what you've heard those monsters
screaming at a distance of course you
got a bad feeling about this this is not
the kind of strange a bad feeling that
classic Star Wars characters have when
they go into the unknown this is a
prequel like bad feeling where the
danger is right in front of them these
raft ours have been gobbling up people
left and right but when it comes to Finn
it's all about stocking the fridge well
how does ray know that this control
board how did she know that button would
close the watch the thrust we're going
on here at Lightspeed but why can't you
just fly out of here and then do that
and since when do you get so cavalier
about Lightspeed the Droid we seek is
aboard the Millennium
in the hands of your father
han Solo in case you forgot what your
father's enables we shall see by the way
is this the rented space where Thanos
and Sinestro conduct all their space
conspiracy business it's at this point
you had a nagging feeling in the back of
your mind that this whole movie was
simply repurposing everything from a new
home and you haven't even gotten to the
new Death Star yet that's got system
this is why you don't bring a highly one
a droid into discount Mos Eisley why
does nobody ever think about this maybe
we should have send this in Return of
the Jedi but Luke decided to bring that
Darth Vader mask with him when he
escaped the second Death Star but why to
symbolically burn it in the Ewok bonfire
later the Death Star was going to blow
it up anyway and way better than that
fire could but now kylo Ren has ik
meaning some enterprising II walk sold
that on eBay to Darth Benjamin 1983
since we last saw I call him I was taken
from a family I'll never know my first
battle I made a choice that was his
first battle he's like 30 how far long
the stormtroopers trained at what age
was he taken Jesus
the truth will confession only brings up
more questions also they sent a rookie
stormtrooper to help find Luke's map key
to Ray's past just happens to be in this
remote and random bar and basically some
lightsaber memory voices draw Rey into
the cantina basement basically is this
an alarm system here our force awakens
we handle all your security needs by
giving thieves scary glimpses of the
past and future that will have everyone
arguing about what it means for use your
thief will be too confused to steal that
lightsaber was Luke's and his father's
before he met him you mean the one that
he was holding when Vader cut his hand
off in Cloud City you mean someone found
that and now it's here artifacts from
the original trilogy are more easily
found than pop-up ads on a porn site
today because we have finally built the
planet moon-sized death machine that
cannot be defeated third time's a charm
[Music]
if you didn't get the Hitler parallel
already here's some stuff to smack your
face with also how does energy this
intense coming from this very
technological Terror they've constructed
not at the very least melt their faces
off like Raiders of the Lost Ark and
what's the point of that anyway they
blow up five planets none of which we
know anything about and for what at
least with the Empire blew of Alderaan
we knew it was latest home planet why
not just go ahead and blow up several
other planets while you're at it and
just end this thing you don't even need
to find Luke anymore soon the first
order is coming down to find Luke's map
but out of this plan coincide with their
mega Death Star plans why didn't they
threaten the five planets first and if
they didn't get the map then they'd
cause mass genocide the first order
might actually be dumber than the Empire
where did you get that a good question
for another time well that's a tidy
screenwriters trick to get out of
explaining hey everybody what's just
mindlessly fire into the building where
the map might be we're giving out wings
I need a weapon
after all I need Joe Schmo can handle
the lightsaber I like this thing cute
moment but that's the first time ever
that Han has fired Chuy's bow caster
seriously okay so he has this badass
staff thing that can deflect lightsabers
but he still threw down his guns so he
could get into a mano a mano sword fight
which is some bolt for duper Jordan
because Rey definitely memorized that
entire map she was shown for 10 seconds
earlier and was told was incomplete
anyway so the resistance swarmed all
over this place but they never once
decided to destroy the ship or kylos
yeah I better be sure to kill random
stormtroopers running around and not
their means of escape Rick god damn
c-3po so Leia should be pretty one with
the force by now right she's had a good
30 years and they made such a big deal
about it in the original trilogy that if
anything happened to Luke her untapped
force magic could save the universe but
appears she's the same old Leia still
awesome but not a Jenna and even but it
matches no charted system on record I
don't know there's a map of this place
unless Luke spent all this time charting
it then found his way back to
civilization then decided to vanish the
movie so far makes us believe that Luke
got upset that kylo turned to the dark
side
and in shame he'd vanished but somehow
he left two pieces of a map of an
uncharted place just before flying away
why is bb-8 curious about what's under
this blanket is it so there's yet
another crowd-pleasing reveal r2d2 r2d2
has been in low-power mode ever since
master Luke went away a metaphor for the
entire Star Wars series actually if
you're a fan of girls then this moment
pulled you straight out of the movie
Adam driver is a good and appealing
actor but once you do something as
unique as his character on that show the
thought of him being a Sith Lord is
hilarious okay it's carrying a section
of a navigational chart and we have the
rest recovered from the archives of the
Empire so that means that is it
uncharted
that lying liar c-3po said just a minute
ago then the resistance must be
destroyed before they get to scarf war
why didn't you just destroy them already
you clearly have the power to do it why
is their ability or non ability to find
Luke so important to that decision just
do it already what do you say about this
girl is true bring her to me
why didn't I low drag her here in the
first place and if you suspect she has
that kind of power she's probably
already convinced stormtrooper Daniel
Craig to set her free you will remove
these restraints and leave this cell
with the door open
Rey realizing she might have Jedi powers
and attempting to use them on the fly is
one of the best things about this movie
and I'm not even shy about giving us in
on kylos walk back to Ray's cell is the
longest walk concocted since Lord of the
Rings yes sir
I've been charging well when we take
approximately all the minutes to charge
welcome to the JJ Abrams roach oh and
you guys how many actors in this scene
were once in well-regarded JJ Abrams TV
shows the clock starts now
it's another Death Star I wish that were
the case major you see because this new
weapon is way larger than the already
huge Death Star it's completely
different some kind of thermal
oscillator there is one precinct 47 okay
Finn spent time on the star killer base
as a stormtrooper but how does he know
that some things never change
true crazy star wars General Hospital
we're making our landing approach at
Lightspeed Finn would be amazing at
cinemasins from the sheer momentum alone
the Falcon should be toast at this point
and it's gonna crash there all sorts
before it comes to a stop I mean we're
not talking about a ship nearly going
fast it was going faster than the speed
a mother flight time for Hollywood's
expert rendition of paper football
touchdown super important star killer
base we think they'd have surveillance
cameras basically everywhere but they do
not wait is there going to be enough
room in this compartment when that big
metal thing goes back into it lower the
shields and now here is the scene where
the suppose at badass captain phasma
Lord of the stormtroopers lets down the
shields like an asshole instead of
standing up to Finn dining and winning
the day for the first order in the
process this whole base is looking for
rain can't find her these two dicks just
happen to luck out and find her at this
very moment in the movie and they go
from senior across the way to right in
her path without so much as a wrong turn
and their weapon will be fully charged
in 10 minutes it would take a miracle to
save us now c-3po somehow never saw Star
Wars
every dramatic Star Wars finale needs to
be set in a giant whatchamacallit
complete with Han Solo death bridge with
narrow walkways and heights that would
kill a Sherpa just by looking at
yep Ben was named after obi-wan that guy
neither Leonor Han had a real
relationship with anyone that doesn't
know at this point that Han is dead just
doesn't know movies and it makes me wish
the film did more to hide this reveal
it's not Star Wars if someone doesn't
fall a thousand stories Leia can sense
when Han has been killed halfway across
the galaxy but still no idea where her
living Jedi brother is without a map do
I have that right Chewie scores a hit
against kylo and then suddenly the
stormtroopers are alerted to his
presence as if the two very loud
Chewbacca growls during Hans death
didn't do that in the first place
also Chewie stops firing at kylo Ren
because stormtroopers start shooting at
him Chewbacca has been through a lot he
knows how well they aim he could have
shot kylo at least 10 more times before
engaging with them speaking of which so
could Rey and Finn but they just stand
there Admiral their weapon will fire in
two minutes more like 10 but it sounds
super urgent doesn't it
why is this supposed to be an insult
it's not like finn made friends in the
first order and it's some huge betrayal
kylo does not have to engage with finn
in a lightsaber duel he could just throw
him with a little force magic but he
gets in a lightsaber duel anyway
I realize it's possible thin is a force
user and doesn't know it in fact I'd say
it's positive since otherwise someone as
powerful as kylo has been shown to be he
should finish him off in about three
seconds flat did you see what he did to
Ray and she is a force user well damn
that's just awesome right there we will
remove three sins for this badassery
oh yeah I better cut back to the
copy-paste space battle for a second so
everyone remembers that's coming on
right now to weapon fully charged in 30
seconds nope sure is good at the planet
to wait to explode so they can have this
fight where you strike sky low in the
face with a lightsaber and it does not
kill him no a perfect grip just four
between them so that sequels can have it
thank the force Rey and Finn we're both
on the same side of the sudden Gorge
that appeared tonight the role of Lord
of the Rings Eagles will be played by
Chewbacca massive planet explodes but as
long as you show the ships flying away
from it there's no way that big
explosion can catch up to them right now
Ray's thinking how do I tell this woman
I stood and gaped as her husband was
betrayed and killed by a guy we all
should have realized was evil or she's
thinking this is a really long hug with
a stranger
artoo suddenly wakes up because time to
end this thing with one last emotional
whammy r2d2 meet a better you bb-8 meet
the previous holder of the cutest Star
Wars droid title I still don't
understand this map like do you actually
need to follow the path Luke draws out
and orange on this thing wasn't a simple
dot that says I am here suffice and
leaving r2 with everything except one
missing piece where you worried
someone's gonna hack into him hadn't
found her long-lost brother she's been
searching
for years Leia sends the strange girl
she just met and Chewbacca why isn't she
coming herself also where the is Lando
and they destroyed the Starkiller base
and found Luke Skywalker all in one day
that's like probably the best day the
resistance will ever have do you think
Luke was maybe a passenger on oceanic
flight 815 geez this is an awful lot of
staring at silence for this moment
I guess Lucas stunned that someone
solved his deviously plotted map foiled
again and honestly I'd rather have the
movie end with ray flying off to look
for Luke as opposed to this final scene
of her finding him and him looking old
and tired this entire final scene his
fanservice plain and simple it makes no
sense for the actual story the story as
presented ends more naturally on the
mystery of not knowing if Rey even finds
Luke but whatever you sold your toys so
who gives a drink now sometimes you make
a copy of a copy it's not quite as sharp
as wellthey original well that's kind of
what happened Leeds loved it he loved it
because he just you know very experiment
got a great deal on her - ever since
cinemasins began the most requested
thing has been TV since and now it's a
reality click the link in the
description below to check it out and
now the audio outtakes
I will find you finishes like the map
all of them turn here I'm Luke Skywalker
I'm here to rescue you hey what's your
name fn-2187 s what that's the only name
they ever gave me take care of yourself
I guess it's what you're best at isn't I
should have gotten there don't go in
there promise me you don't go in there
me go in there that's the last place I
want to go like I'm gonna go in there
try getting a boner now the power of the
Sun in the palm of my hand I love you
I know you have to go back we have to go
back we have to go back madam an express
elevator
dinah guys snag on takeoff splashdown
sucked into a vortex nuggets